el triunfo de los liberales demócratas
en north crop cha en las últimas horas
se traduce en una derrota significativa
para el primer ministro boris johnson y
su partido el conservador dado que está
sola en el norte de inglaterra llegando
a gales es uno de sus bastiones
electorales para darles un ejemplo de lo
significativo esta silla que desde ahora
ocupará la liberaldemócrata helen morgan
ha estado en manos de los conservadores
desde hace 200 años y es que esta ha
sido una semana particularmente difícil
para el primer ministro quien vive una
crisis de credibilidad y de autoridad
por los escándalos de las fiestas de
navidad en downing street en 2020 y
también en otros edificios del gobierno
que rompieron claramente todas las
reglas de las restricciones por la
pandemia
pese a que el premier las ha negado
aunque cada día se exponen nuevas
evidencias en la prensa hace apenas unos
días en el parlamento sufrió una
rebelión de 100 de sus diputados sólo
los votos del partido laborista el de
oposición
salvar el plan b que ha tenido que ser
activado por el peligro que omicron
significa para el reino unido está en el
malestar con boris johnson que en su
partido el conservador ha empezado a
abrirse la puerta para una posible
elección en 2022 sobre su liderazgo y
sobre si debe continuar como primer
ministro